it didn't look like catching to me when i was watching jd redo it it looked completely
no it's legit man it's freaking legit it's legit yeah
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing
i'm not sure you all know this but two of the most respected hackers in the ctbb
community bus factor and xss doctor are now running monthly hack alongs on the ctbb discord okay
you've got to check this out ctbb.show discord we find bugs almost every time we hack it's crazy
and and oftentimes it's not even the people running the hack alongs it's the the community
members that are hacking along with us it you definitely increase your chance of finding a bug
by being on these hack alongs so check them out ctbb.show discord join bus xss doctor and yours truly
and let's pop some bugs all right let's go back to the show
all righty doc it has been a long time in the making thanks for joining us on the pod
um we got we're starting like 30 minutes late because we got so distracted talking about
all the research and the fun stuff um in advance so we got to bring it to the people as well um but as
always let's start off with the bug and then we'll we'll get into intros so um you put four here in the
doc let's uh let's start with the or no let's start with the i like that one first i think we're gonna
have to mute that one that word out that you just said that's good thanks for having me on i'm super
excited to be here i've always wanted to be on this podcast um so fine let's talk about this bug from a
um so i'm gonna uh the the bug is uh from let's say a a company that makes home automation
software uh that can sometimes be controlled by an ai okay and that ai um is what i was hacking and so um
actually it starts with grep me asking me to collab and i was like pretty excited every time like a big
hacker asked me to collab i say yes and i get really excited about it um and i and like we started hacking
and like he found something immediately you know some idor and put me on the report so i was like all right
i have to like really show up talk about motivation you know yeah i hate it when that happens oh my god
and i was like i was kind of busy at work too and i'm like all right enough like like we got i got to
get this bug done so i'm like looking at this particular ai and um the ai it was is a very powerful
ai it has access to basically everything that the user of this has in their whole life including if they
have home automation set up it is this particular you can just control the house you could just type
into the ai turn off my alarm and it will turn off the alarm so it's extremely powerful so like the
first thing you look at is i'm like if i can prompt inject into this ai i'm like god uh for this for
this situation so i obviously i look for all the parameter look for a q parameter i mean a q parameter
would be extremely silly to have on this app and it was correct we didn't have it but there was a post
message listener that you could send a post message through this listener and it would it would just
pop up um as a prompt injection now it i think it was meant for a chrome extension to use um but
the origin check had star dot this target dot com as as part of the origin check so if you had xss on any
anything in the entire ecosystem of this program you could send this post message into this ai and
control the entire their entire life so i'm like okay like i need to get i need to get access i mean
it's a huge ecosystem so i i you know i figured there was probably excess i've actually had found xss
before but didn't know about this gadget so i'm looking around and i actually the first thing i look at
when i'm looking for xss is usually file upload um when i'm like looking for easier xss um and so i i
actually uploaded a file to this ai and uh and and and i could upload arbitrary html and i could visit it
but um but um it was an attachment so then i'm like i think that there are there are like pre-production
uh domains on this on this ai so i i go to all the pre-production domains i which are identical
and i upload the my html payload and one of them did not have it as an attachment no that is that is a good idea dude
yeah and so i i make the bug i submit the bug and i get and when i do that when i do the file upload i
always test it on a guest profile to see if it's if it's not a self xss right there are no login c
surfs on this on this target it's extremely locked down for login c surf so a self xss cannot be escalated
or i couldn't find a way so i i tested on the guest profile and it pops so i'm like i'm good i'm solid
like all i have to do is send this and it sends a post message um and i'm and the the setup of the
of the bug was kind of interesting because you couldn't have the ai in the background you had to
have it on the foreground because for some reason it wouldn't send the prompt in the background um
so i yeah it was really weird which actually kind of takes away from the impact of the bug a little
bit because yeah they're seeing they're seeing like turn off for your alarm system
i wonder if you could do the same sort of thing we did in that hack along that one time though where
we like popped it up in a little box yes you know like oh yeah and i did it i popped in a little box
and make it made a little bit a little bit better looking uh but it still looks like and that's what
i did i popped it up in a little box yeah but i didn't like that popping up in the front thing yeah
so i looked further into it and what was the what was it doing when you were turning on the alarm
system there was an api it was calling an api had the same cores as the post message had so it had
access control allow origin star.target.com with the pre-flight so i didn't even need the post
message anymore but then i hit same site same site lacks default cookies or are they same site none
explicit it no the the auth system of this program is uh at the level of the tlt you know like there's
not a separate off for every oh yeah every no no no because you've got an xss so you're saying i have
an xss exactly so i didn't even need the post message anymore i could just get the xss and have it hit
this api so i'm like thinking i'm this is the greatest bug i've ever found in my life yeah yeah i submit
it i'm i first thing i do is i message grep me because you know i want him to be impressed with
me yeah and uh and he is yeah and he is impressed with me we know that he is and he is yeah i think
around the same time i got a message from grep me like dude jd is god you know like yeah yeah and i
message everybody about this everybody i know i'm so excited i think both of you got messages from me and
and and bus factor everybody that i know and about a week later i get that they couldn't reproduce it
and i'm like oh my god it turns out that that guest profile i had tested it on i had logged into the
app on a different window in that guest profile no and it was indeed a self xss oh my gosh yeah and
yeah so i'm like i'm like ready to die like i i've never i i had told everybody about this bug it was
the best book i've ever found and so i messaged them back like listen give me a week please to find
another xss please and then i'll close it if you don't find it and they're like fine and so i'm i'm
going crazy i have ai armies out there trying to find xss i have everything i'm messaging demo do you
have an xss here like i need that on the last day you know yeah and so on the last day i had looked at
this other ai this company had a lot and i'm like i'm just gonna do this one last time and then i'm just
gonna close it and just tail between my legs that's the end of hacking for me forever and i upload
i upload the same thing on a different ai it again is an attachment and i'm like you know i
think this also has a pre-production endpoint but this is a little bit different this bug because there
was like a parameter that said path on the bottom so like if you uploaded it to but then it said slash
uploads okay if you upload html to slash uploads it would it would fail but you could put after the
word uploads slash hello and then it would upload anything you wanted to slash upload slash hello slash
whatever this md5 something was and it would let me know what anything i wanted unauthenticated and that
was nice and i was an authentic xss and then you weren't getting attachment disposition nope on the
pre-production endpoint with that path thing i could i just visited it it was the last day of my testing
and i got the everything and i submitted everything and it went through and gret me was again very
impressed with me dude i love the conclusion of that story that was what it was all about in the end jd you
have nothing to prove man you've yeah seriously for a very long time no but still it's still you know
you're no he got that eye door and at least i got at least i found a fun ball no i totally get it though
i mean i feel the same way actually i'm hacking with franz and every time i hack with franz and matthias
we have hacked with franz videos for years but every single time i hack with franz and matthias i feel the
same way because those bastards pull out like all the vulnerabilities like as soon as you start hacking
they're like oh i just found this and i'm like what oh my god all right now i gotta keep up with that
so um yeah no i totally get it and uh yeah i think that there's a couple really good takeaways from
that story one which is pre-prod might allow you to bypass the the content disposition stuff so
excellent excellent insight the fact that it worked twice in your scenario is very interesting and then
um also kind of that's another really interesting thing to check for content disposition is uploading it
to a different directory because maybe directory specific download rules are in place where it's like
okay if it slash uploads then we do it as a attachment but if it slash you know whatever else anything
else yeah very nice dude very nice dude two very solid takeaways you're impressed too it was totally
worth it the whole thing was worth it well i think that's probably the world's best xss escalation too like
like you know xss to your alarm systems off you know like i know that that was the real world impact is
like the best yeah i love real world impact i and i that's my goal for the year just just you know text
your victim right text your victim be like your package is here they click the link now their alarms
off you know like they're getting to the house and rob the house that's exactly right a real criminal could
use that that like i love the idea that a real criminal i have stopped a real like maybe they
could have maybe they would have stopped i mean i think i actually think smart lock i think smart
lock or smart garage door is even more impactful though like if you can just open someone's garage
door up or unlock their door this could do that too right this could do all of that stuff it could
open everything i love that dude i feel like jd is the kind of guy you know he's so context y'all he's a
doctor already so he's making good money right yeah but i feel like he's the kind of guy that would do it
and then just rob the house just for like i exploded it and i did it i would do i wouldn't
just rob it i would put stuff in the house i would put stuff inside the house yeah exactly get
in the house still get in there put a picture of this report as a critical yes dude we have to tell
that story jd oh my gosh we can't tell the company but we have to tell that story that should be the
next bug okay all right um jd i mean you got a couple more bugs man i'm a sucker for a good bug story
what do you want to do next all right i'll tell one more bug that actually is rezo and i's bug if
you notice i hack better when high level hackers ask me that hack with them i i like try to bring my
game and that's it so we rezo and i were hacking on another site that um is an e-signature platform
um and basically the way it works is that you um the you make a uh you make a contract and the contract
you send it to the person you want to sign it and they get it in an email and then they click that link
and then they sign it and that and uh and we found that the the person who creates the contract there's
another api endpoint that really wasn't that visible that you could get to that would let the creator of
the contract see the link that was sent to the recipient of the contract so you put you basically
make a contract and then sign it on behalf of the person who you were sending it to and it just said that
they signed like when you clicked the sign thing it was their name that was that was signed and so we
i mean to me that's the highest level that this this app can offer right but when we submitted to
them they tried to close this thing like three times on us justin yes no joke they're still debating
whether or not they're going to accept it yeah so like they basically said that it wasn't it wasn't
the triage or it was the actual like developers or like we made it like this so that because we didn't
want the recipient to to anyway it doesn't matter what they were working about it's a design principle
thing is it was a design principle but you do run into these issues from time to time where the
programs are a little bit more resistant because it's like okay well for the business use case the use
ease of access is like oh we should be able to sign this unauthenticated or whatever but at the end of
the day if you're leaking the url they should leave the url that's the bug the bug is the leaking if
they don't want to do that anyway but so what i did is i used this to create a contract with the
security team of the program of the company saying this is a critical bug and will be paid as a critical
bug and that you and that you agree and i signed up on their behalf of them and i sent it in the report
oh my gosh yeah you're contractually obligated to get a critical yeah and i and i i i was thinking
when they pulled back again of being like you signed the contract it says here you signed the
contract i don't know what you're what we're debating about now can you prove to me you didn't
sign this contract because if not yeah you can't prove it's not in the audit trail says you signed
this contract yeah we can go to court over this like you agreed to it yeah in the in the contract
like it shows what their email or like what yeah their email their name there's nothing that identifies
the creator of the contract as the signer do they need to have an account on that website or is that's
why they say that's their argument that they don't want the recipient to have an account on the website
they want anybody to be able to sign it but that's great but then the link should be yeah private
the link is the security feature yeah the security mechanism then is that you got that link via email
right and then the only reason that it's not just anybody signing it is because you got that link in
your email right so if you thus you have access to your email and nobody else does thus it must be you
signing it right so that's it that's exactly a little sense man that makes little sense it's a good bug i
like i said that in the contract that was part of the contract that was funny oh my gosh very good man
well i feel like uh i feel like we could kind of go back and forth all day on um on stories but let's uh
let's actually intro you um so uh guys this is xss doctor he's been running hack alongs for us for a
while now so most of you guys that are like hardcore in the community know him um but i will just say i'll
brag on you a little bit and then i'll let you do a self intro as well but i think xss doctor is like
one of the people that has kind of grown up in bug bounty in this community in the ctvb community that
i am most proud of like if i think of like oh you know what effect says the ctvb community hat you know
had on a bug bounty at all at large and the fact that xs doctor has you know grown up in this environment
is like one of my proudest you know things um and yeah i just have so much respect for
you as a ackerman like the amount of passion you bring very very rarely does the amount of
passion somebody brings to bug bounty actually rival my own but i i feel i feel like uh you know
we have very very similar very compatible levels of a passion for bug bounty and it's very contagious
and passion for front end and passion for front end right and uh just seeing the way you you tear apart
frameworks and apps and like and just get right to the meat um it's just it's very inspiring man so
you're definitely a hacker i respect a ton and i'm very glad to have you thank you well i mean i'm only
for real i only learned front end because of you like i i'm not i'm not that's not a joke like i i
didn't even know about it like i would listen to the podcast and i'm like this guy seems that's it seems
fun what he's doing and then that's why i learned all this stuff dude that's i'm so glad to hear that
man um you're also also a doctor right your name is xss doctor um so to give us a little bit of
background of like how you landed on bug bounty as a cardiologist and uh where you're at in life now i
guess like oh yeah so i basically i was uh i started practice in 2019 i finished fellowship and then like
i was like all about you know being a cardiologist and then like covet happened in 2020 2021 and like
coveted it was really crazy time in medicine uh for a lot of reasons but like for me it was weird
because like everyone was dying of coveted and nobody was coming into the hospital for heart disease
but i was still consulted for all the coveted patients because they had high cardiac enzymes that's
kind of a side of them anyway and so i was like both very stressed and depressed about everybody dying
that i was seeing and kind of bored uh because i wasn't doing any cardiology and i had a very small
child that my that like when you have one kid it's mostly your my wife now i have two kids and it's
like kind of half and half but so i was like getting home early and i was bored and depressed and kind of
like didn't you know and i'm like scrolling on my phone and i see this like learn to be a hacker in 12
hours go from beginner to intermediate level is what it said i'm not going to say the name and this was
like one of these fake classes yeah but i i'm like i want to that sounds awesome like that's the coolest
thing i've ever heard what i took an algorithm showed you that like that's what i want to know
like i just want to know what was in the algorithm of like instagram or whatever that's like okay jd is
the most nerd snipable human uh and what could we get him to think that is cool that you know like
and they're like hacker that's amazing it was on flipboard yeah oh you ever heard of flipboard no
that's like that's because i'm old that's like predates i still have it on my phone it's like when
you flip and it like will show you a different article every time and so i took the class it was
obviously fraudulent but um but it was i was like obsessed i like didn't know about cali downloaded
cali linux and um and then like i'm like all right i i even realized then this was bs but i i'm like i
go on reddit r hacking and i'm like you know how they had that like thing on the top and when they were
like um how to be a real hacker like and it's like don't be a script kitty do ctfs that's what that posted
thing said that ctf players if you could be ctf player you could hack anything is what that thing
said so i spent the next like year and a half doing cts uh mostly hacked the box and like obsessed
with ipsec which i still am by the way i love ipsec and um and doing like if i'm like i don't even care
about hacking if i could just do extreme box i'm that's all i care about in life you know like i was
just so into it and like i spent that time i'm like learning python and like i'm like i'm like trying
to do these boxes and i'm and then by the time i could do an extreme box i'm like all right right
post said i'm a hacker yeah i am a master hacker in fact yeah you know i'm an extreme hacker and so
i'm like i think like what kind of hacking am i legally allowed to do and i knew about bug bounty
so i started to look at bounty bug bounties and i'm like i don't even know what i'm looking at right
now like i've never what that is this you know like i it's i don't know how many people have had
that experience like where you're doing ctfs and to hack the box and try hack me when you look at the
kaido output or the burp output of a real website it looks drastically different than that oh yeah
totally and the types of bugs you look for are drastically different like i thought everything
was going to be like php to rce yeah you know a vhv lfi to rce to me that was i was going to find that
every day yeah um and then i took jason's haddix's bug bounty methodology course and i found my first
couple bugs during that um and i started hacking sort of in that method for a while
but it with that um type of wide scope packing you need a competitive i find that you need a competitive
advantage like extremely good automation or like some something that makes you better than the people
with the automation which i did not have and then i started listening to podcasts and that's kind of
where i and i i realized i'm like why am i finding that many bugs and and then you were finding a lot of
bugs so i'm like let's let's see what the hacking like this guy would be like yeah and and that's kind
of how i got into client side dude that's that's amazing man yeah that is a that is such a amazing
journey and i'm so glad that i was a part of that uh that just gives me goosebumps that's why we do pod
um i i i do want to jump back to i guess a function of your rhetoric that keeps coming out which is and
this was the most important thing in my life you know and like and you're like this was and then i felt like
you know that i if i could just solve an extreme box then it would just be like the whole purpose of
my existence you know like like and i i often find you know myself talking like that as well as like
if i could just like pop this this bug this would like make my life you know um i can't sleep yeah i
think i think i think that is if i had to to if i had to guess i think that is probably one of the
reasons why you have the success that you've had is that like super strong passion all in like this is
what is this is the thing i am very decided and focused that this is the thing that is the most
important to me right now you know yeah it's very goal oriented too and i think that it is and it's also
kind of hopeful like it's optimistic i think the mix of passion optimism and goal-oriented thinking
is like a really really um strong mix for success and a lot of top hackers that's a really good way to
put it i agree with that and i see a lot of hackers like fearing towards negativity and i think that
hurts them a lot when they don't find bugs or when they when they get some bad situation with triage
you know i think that's a really good way to do it because i think that's a really good way to do it
and i think that's a really good way to do it and i think that's a really good way to do it
and i think that's a really good way to do it but i think that's a really good way to do it
um and it's possible that your passion is just you know bottomless and endless but i also heard a
little bit of like if i don't pop this bug i'm gonna quit bug bounty forever and this is the end of
my life and i i hate my life you know so there are a lot of ups and downs with this right so i in more
so than i i would ask the normal um you know guest on critical thinking i want to ask you how do you deal
with the ups and downs of this being such an extreme person and is burnout a part of your your flow
yeah i'm not gonna i'm i'm i'm actually not the right person to ask about this because i'm
completely different than everybody i not everybody a lot of people at least because i i don't like this
is solely for fun and so when i don't like doing one aspect of hacking i will switch completely at a
whim to a different completely different like i'll like like i stopped hacking once for four months to
learn go you know what i mean like yeah like i just i don't care about doing that and if i'm into doing
that like i i was i did a lot of i did coding for a while i helped with that fat with fabric uh and
that's i did that like for months i didn't hack basically because that was just really into that
and i think that that that stops me from burning out um like just following like a like a passion and
being able financially to do that is very helpful and i think it's made me a better hacker in the end but
it's made me make less money in the end because um like i don't go five days straight on a target in
order to find 50 bugs yeah which would make me more money um i don't think i can do that uh like in my
life i don't have enough time to do that right um but anyway that's that's my answer i'm not gonna burn
out because of that i've asked you before though like if you have such passion for it would you go
full-time bug bounty what is that i spent a lot of time being a doctor like i spent a lot of time
trying to be a doctor like it might like it i i finished training when i was like 2019 i was like
36 like i i basically like i it was like decades of my life and it's hard it's fun being a doctor i
love being a doctor and i have like all these patients that need me i don't think i can not i
don't think i can stop doing that i will say justin this thought has crossed my mind a lot too
because uh for listeners that don't know basically my entire hackbot system me and jd
are just kind of 50 50 on and there's a lot of reasons for that like i think there's a lot of
really cool things like you know he's able to triage like front-end stuff that i'm that i would
struggle to triage and lots of other things i actually think that people should probably
partner half and half on on um hackbot creation because you get twice as much velocity and anyways
i'll i'll table that for now but um the one thing that i have thought a lot about justin is like if
if he and i do you know a million in bounties this year just like completely crazy it goes
really well well could i talk him into it and i think that the best i could do a million dollars
i know we never mentioned a million dollars here and i think the best i could do is talk him down
to like part-time work you know yeah i don't know it it it depends on a lot of things it's it's hard
there's no such thing as part-time it's a cardiologist it doesn't i know part-time
cardiologists and they still work full-time it's hard to be a part-time cardiologist yeah yeah i
imagine so and it's and it's something i think there's also a weight to that as a as a physician
like you and this is something we've talked to i think when we went out to dinner that one time it's
like well you know if you're so passionate about bug bounty but you're also a cardiologist like you
you've got to really be disciplined in that you need to be paying you know sufficient attention to
your profession because it's not something that is like you can just skate by on as if you're like a
government employee you know yeah yeah it's a lot of pressure there's a lot of pressure for your
patient and you can make one mistake and like their life is over obviously your life is is also harmed a
great deal yeah by that one mistake but yeah so that's intense man i think that you're living a
very intense um you know environment there but but i think you've also mentioned like your work hours
are pretty good and that you can still find time to hack and stuff like that and you can reschedule
patients and it's too efficient yeah it's my efficiency yeah it's which anyway yeah i can do a whole podcast
on efficiency yeah well i i know we actually should do that i think it's like a superpower yeah i i know
we said we were going to focus on the research but the research but so one last question though you
context switch a lot right which i think is something that is a lot of hackers struggle with
particularly me i need focused i mean actually you know sort of the the the environment around you
you know forces you to evolve so now that i have kids i am getting a little bit better at like
you know dealing with distraction then coming back but you do it in a way that i've never seen which is
i've got a patient now i've got six minutes to hack and i hack and then i go back you know like yeah so
that's that's not uh that's not a super that's in my disease like i have add uh that used to be
medicated when i was in high school right and then i did i stopped medicating my add and i just figured
out how to live my life in such a way that works with my brain and that includes if i'm doing something
that i'm not having fun doing i can do it in short spurts and then switch to another not
fun activity and then switch back and i'm able to do that but if i'm obviously if i'm into a thing
like if i'm in the middle of a bug chain i could do that for like a week without sleeping but if i'm
doing like recon on a target which i'm i'm not a huge fan of that then i have to context switch
frequently in order to complete the task but that is my brain thing and not like what i suggest for
others around me but it helps me in context switching to like medicine and hacking and my kids
um and stuff but that's wow very interesting dude i don't i don't know how that works for you but uh more
power to you because it's clearly getting results you have the opposite you have something that nobody else
has which is you have like the the hyper focus of add without having add and you just have it all the
time like that's like that's like that's an actual superpower like we we have i have a problem yes
actually actual i i wish i could get on something like ritalin so i could do what justin does but
i literally it's unreal yeah it's unreal it is it is a little bit odd too man i i do think um just as
like a you know i don't know self-proclaimed neurotypical here uh like i do i do really value
the fact that i can just sit down and focus for a very long time and like you know stay locked in
and stuff like that but i mean you really do feel it when your body is off too like if you get a bad
i've got this whoop right if you get a bad you know night's sleep or you know you're just not your
body's not at you know good performance levels or whatever like i'm sitting here i'm trying to focus
i'm like man why can i not like focus on this you know so it is crazy when as you become more aware
of it you you learn how to like optimize your your life around that if you're really trying to focus
hard um i have to feel physically good in order to hack well i agree if even if i have one drink the
night before i'm older than you guys so i like one drink is a lot is a lot for me i mean even though
i do it but uh but i'm a worse hacker the next day even with one drink yeah i stopped being able to
process alcohol at like 25 like at 25 like i started you know if i had a glass of wine i would
feel it like the next day actively and i'm like all right well guess i'm done with that so i i don't
drink anymore um but yeah so all that aside let's get to the technical meat well richard go ahead and put
in a cut here as well you know for like if people want to like jump to this point uh in the podcast
um let's get to the research okay so you i messaged you about this episode and i was like hey man you
know maybe we could do something with like client-side paths or like client-side path traversal and then
you're like sure thing and then like i come over and there's like this book on client-side path traversals
there's an app on client-side path parsing there's like the nuances of every single framework outlined
i swear dude that and and i've read through it all and it's like beautifully written uh did you ever see
the prices right you ever see this other prices yes i have you know when they call the person down
and and that person is all excited to be on the prices right because they've been watching it for
years right i am currently right now on the price is right and you have called me down like are you
gonna are you gonna is this gonna be a bad episode no no this is not gonna be a bad episode this
better be a fantastic episode this is so funny because we just view you as our friend and you literally
lead hack along it's like you've popped bugs during justin's stream like you're not different
you're not so you guys every thursday that's my routine for years for years oh man that's amazing
dude frick i love this i love this community okay um so we now have a very long research paper uh that
will be going on the research lab so uh you can find that at lab.ctbb.show and uh that outlines
client-side path traversals across every single major framework by our boy exercise doctor yeah you
should take one minute to tell us uh how you wrote that because justin loved it okay yeah okay so yeah
let me set the scene for that great great lead in rezo um as i read through this i was like oh man
like jd sat down here and like wrote this like by hand every single line and you know that's so rare
nowadays with ai is that actually what happened because it actually actually the answer is this what
you're reading was written by me but the the process by which was written by me is slightly different so like
basically this is let me talk about the research first then we can talk about how i did it basically
um i started out by i uh i love client-side path traversal is my favorite bug uh class and i love
playing with client-side paths the first thing i look at ever on a on a target is is all the client-side
paths same and i when i'm looking for clients like that traversal i basically i don't even look at the code in the beginning i just like find a path that looks like it's custom
like slash settings slash xss doctor and then i'll start putting in coding at the end of that percent
2f percent 25 2f percent 5c sometimes unicode all but for some reason now i understand why but it never
it doesn't work the unicode uh often and so and then i'll i'll look for an api call on the back end
i'll often also use bus factors fantastic uh gecko extension which i do all the time which basically
is just looking for reflection in the api call and then um if i find that and i find traversal
on the back end i'll then look to see if um if if there's any impact of that whether it's a c-surf
or xss um but when justin asked me to do this client-side path episode i thought it would be cool to
like look through every framework and to find out why it was sometimes working why percent 2f sometimes
works it doesn't 5c like is it just like the developer doing something weird or is there something
that is unique to the frameworks so i looked at uh nine i actually looked at 10 frameworks in
the beginning but i i thought it was too long so i ended up just doing it on eight and so that's uh
react uh next ember view angular something called solid state um am i missing one so nuxt i did nuxt
also um i think that's it and so um and spell kit and spell kit yeah and so the way that i
did it was that i had ai build me labs that's the first thing i did is i say build me a lab for react
i want it to have um this so basically like take a path parameter and and uh put it into an api call
take a query parameter put into api call how is it doing that and then i would i would look at it
play with it and then ask ai um yeah ask ai that's really good that's a really good flow sorry i know
i was i was gesturing with my hands here for those that are on audio but um yeah that's a really good
way of doing it too because the ai of course is going to produce the code that is most common
that it was trained off of right so if you're looking to like replicate common code patterns
used by developers in the specific language then that's like ai is right you know like that's
that's so so you had to generate all the labs and then you work back from there or so i st i would do
the labs and i'd i'd find the places that it worked on and then i would ask ai to point me to the code
in the developer code like in the react code for example to it's like where is this parsed how is this
parse like like when um so like thinking about let's say that's client-side path example for um so like
you're a developer and you want to make a you want to make a path to um the slash about like that's
easy right like you just like basically say slash about this is the javascript you want to be on that
page this is what you want the page to look like but let's say you want slash settings slash xss doctor
that xss doctor is going to be custom for every user and so that is going to be defined a certain way in
every different framework um and so like in react for example um it would be like slash sledding
settings slash colon user id and so then i thought the developer needs to get that somehow and then use
that in a way that however they want to use it they have to get that information because
if i was a developer and i wanted to make let's say slash settings slash xss doctor and then i would
make an api call to slash api slash xss doctor right api v1 xss doctor uh they would what they would
do is they'd get that value as a variable and then pass it into the api call which is actually how it works
you know and in react that would be on the front end sometimes it's on the back end we talk about that
and so um i had ai point me towards the exact code and i would keep asking questions i'd be like
what's it doing here like why is it doing this like what is this what is this um and then i would look
at it with ai to find out so that's how i did the research to trace it through the various components in
yes reacts internal repository or whatever framework correct okay and then i would i would say why is it
you are all decoding here like what's happening here like what's the function show me that function
so i would i would do that um and then i had all the research done for all the things and then i'm like
write the blog article for me just write it you know here are some blogs i've written before put make
it sound like that yeah that's literally what i did and i wrote it and i'm like this is pretty good so i
sent it out to like rezo and and demo and you although you didn't read it thank god um and that you
and they wouldn't have liked it and uh bus factor and everyone's like this is okay but like i could just
get ai to write me a blog like why did you get ai to write me a blog true true so then i rewrote it all
myself yeah i think i think it feels okay so so then what you did is you looked at the blog post
and then you like hand rewrote it is that is that right yeah i hand rewrote everything i know i just
started at the beginning i didn't like hand rewrite line by line like i i just wrote my own blog article
okay there are certain lines i left in from the ai yeah and some of them maybe you could tell they're in
there uh but i couldn't personally there were many there i i left mostly it was me uh in this particular
one uh because i once uh uh submitted a bug with you and i had ai write the report and you were quite
unhappy with that report um and i felt bad it wasn't good bro it was not good i know i felt really bad
it when you when you when you so i'm like i can't submit a blog article in your defense it actually
did get triaged got paid i don't know two days later it did i i like i said i messaged you and i was
like look jd this is like this is awful and this doesn't have like a a very actionable poc like everything's
terrible where is the click and see impact right yeah like i really think that that's essential like you
you you and you did have a you know there's a ton of stuff there's a lot of detailed information it
was like you know it outlined everything but as a as a you know as a i don't know as a person reading
the report i wanted to see go to this link click and then note what happens on their site you know
that sort of thing i didn't see it but somehow you're right it was a terrible article it was a terrible it
was a terrible no you were right and i felt bad not because of you but because i i'm like i that was not the
best work i could have done there but it's so it's so seductive to have ai write the report for you it
is because it's so boring sometimes to write the report sometimes it depends on the bug if i love
the bug if a bug is part of my heart i like writing it but if the bug is not part of my heart and it's
just like i like i don't like writing it the bug is part of my heart dude let me give like a like just
like two really quick tips from for writing better reports you know 90 people listening probably already
do this but if you don't definitely tell it to be concise and just technical and leave out any kind
of fluff but the other thing that i found that is really really um good for having it right good
reports justin especially for what you're talking about is i've told to always use attacker victim
language and be extremely clear about when the victim does or like sorry given these preconditions
because like often the ai whenever it starts to write that would be like wait the precondition is that
you're already a super admin oh man this actually isn't a bug right so like you know
make make sure it gives the preconditions for what the victim is and what the attacker is
and then make sure that it frames it in attacker victim language so you know an attacker would set up
this and then a victim would do this and then this outcome will occur and that massively improves our
reports yeah yeah i imagine it's i don't know it depends on the bug it's it's it's very hard for me
because sometimes i just want to i found the bug i just want to submit it yeah i think at the end of
the day like you should definitely write concise technical you know to the point reports right i think
and this is actually something i said on the goals a goals episode at the beginning this year you know
i want to do better detail you know in my reports but i think if you're gonna skimp somewhere skimp on the
report and don't skip on the poc like if your poc speaks for itself there is a high chance that the
company will like take that report seriously right if you're if if you're you know and when justin says
poc he doesn't just mean like the actual script he means like the video showing exactly what happens
yeah the video the the actual script it's itself you know all of that it you know they will fill in
the blanks on the report right uh or they will ask you to fill in the blanks on the report if you
write a report with no poc and no you know video then it's it's hard for them to go from zero context to
oh i read through this thing and i know you know how it works and i can actually implement it myself
you know given none of your pre-knowledge right so um i don't know i think that's i think if you're
going to skimp on on one area definitely don't make it the the poc um i'm going to try to do them all
myself anyway yeah i think that's good i think that's good all right let's get to the research so um
i mean just having read through it essentially what this research shows and you can correct me
where it where i'm wrong in any way is an analysis of the these frameworks how um path parameters career
parameters hash parameters are parsed across the frameworks and even some server-side rendering stuff
which was very interesting to me um and then uh how these cspts actually which is a client-side path
traversal get um in they how they occur within these frameworks what what parsing of the of the
parameters what parsing of the routes should we be looking for and understanding okay you know in this
scenario our percent 2f is going to turn into a slash and we've even got percent 25 2f now that we can
you know utilize in this specific environment uh versus like um understanding where you know what
single page application frameworks are not going to do that um and you're wasting your time looking
for for uh cspts is that is that accurate yeah i mean basically like when we're in this situation
the source is going to be something in the url bar and the sync in this just in this for this gadget
is going to be the fetch or the api call so if you think about that like what is the process by which
the the thing that the thing in the url bar gets to the api call to in order to exploit it there's
another sync right there's going to be either the the uh the c surf sync or the xss sync or however
else you want to exploit this or the or the ssrf or secondary path traversal sync um on the server but um so
if you you know in the url bar the um oh good nice yeah i've got the the three places that you that you
may um that you may your three sources there are either the path itself the query parameter or the
hash parameter um the query parameter everyone is always testing this from the query parameter but i like
to start from the path to be honest with my most impactful um cspts have been from the path same
not from the yeah i agree i think i think it actually very often happens in in in the path
parameter more almost more often because there i feel like the developers are looking for it from the
query parameter more or something i also feel like they often take query parameters and put them in
query parameters versus like path values get put in path value yes does that make sense yeah that's that's
yeah and interestingly in my research the path was the most interesting um i found the most interesting
things basically there so um you can even go down go down to like the all the way on the bottom to that
to that um so so like basically for people who are like not client-side people it's like again it's
like the way you have to think about it is that there is each the a front-end javascript framework i
guess just to introduce that is there the pat the path parameter in the url bar is not mapping to a
folder on the server or a file on the server like it would be for like php or like a multi um a multi-page
framework and all these older framework is um instead these uh javascript frameworks they the url bar they
they take what's on the url bar and uh the path in the url and and that will be sent to the code and
the code will use that to determine what shows up on the page what code paths are going down what lazy
loaded javascript files are loaded um what api calls are sent out from from that place and so um when
you have a dynamic path parameter a path parameter that's not like just slash about but like slash
about slash xss doctor slash files slash md5 sum you know um the way that they reference those
as the developer there's a function that they call either on the front or the back end that gets that
value back for the developer and then the developer can do something with that okay and so let me let me
let me pause and and try to summarize and make sure i'm tracking with you okay so unlike you know php or
ias right those are sort of file system based hgp servers right um we've got those and then we've got like
apis right modern modern paths where um a program is actually handling the the parsing of these routes
right so those are two types of paths that we're familiar with then there's also like a third one
which is like a client-side router right which is a a router that is occurring within your own browser
for single page applications so um the javascript code on the client side is parsing the the the path
from the url and then routing you to some specific you know view or or some page within the single page
application uh and that's what we're talking about is dealing with the parameters of those paths so
um the you know like you mentioned slash about slash xss doctor whatever xss doctor might be a
dynamic value there could be slash about slash rhino rater right and what we're while we're looking into
here is how these client-side routing engines parse that dynamic component is that am i am i tracking with
you that's exactly right that's what i wanted to look at that was like the the you know uh for this
part of the research yeah and so um and then another question i had was that which functions in which
frameworks decode by default so if you put in slash xss doctors slash percent 2f or percent 25 2f or percent
5c which i actually have to put back and put in there um which ones are url decoded by default because
that would if it was url decoded by default that would make the developer less likely
or more more likely to have a misconfiguration putting that directly into the api call
um and i found that they all all the frameworks have at least
almost all the frameworks have a way to to have a um a vulnerable way to a vulnerable primitive a
vulnerable function exactly that will take the path parameter and auto decode it as if it was a query
parameter yeah and sometimes double url decoded that's that's crazy man the w i'm looking at the
table here there is on react there's a double url decode the worst thing about react is that there was
actually a issue a github issue um saying that there was a w r l uh decoding bug they fixed it but then
reintroduced it later in a different manner uh so it's there's still anyway uh react it's called the
use params which is important yeah if you're going to take anything away from from this research you should
look at this because this is a great way to to find in the code what's going on um like you know if you
if uh in in use uh in react uh basically the developer would say let squiggly squiggly bracket
user id equals use params and that would bring back that user id um into the code and then if it's
passing that directly into a fetch that's a cspt or it could be doing other stuff with it it could be
putting that directly into a dangerous set inner html you never know um but that's a good way
thing to look at and it will double url decode that okay um view everything is is uh everything is
vulnerable to this angular uh it's pretty vulnerable um uh next
is mostly not vulnerable except uh next has this thing called uh also has a use params function which
is does not auto decode uh the parameter but on the server side it uses something called await params
which is the async version of of use params that is often is almost always used on the server side and
that is auto decoded and if you think about what that means is that if on a next app if you're using
uh server side routing um and you are using a back-end api as opposed to a front-end api
which is next you can kind of choose what you do it can kind of be more front-end or more back-end and
that's kind of why a lot of people use next but why else use next if you're not going to use some
amount of back-end right fanciness and so if you await params uh and then pass that directly to the
back-end api that will lead to secondary context path traversal okay so i'm gonna that's the one
we're gonna double click into for a second okay that's in the in the sync section of this is it okay
so let me see if i can find it here all right so we found it um i'm looking at this so this is a very
interesting case so what you're saying here is that as an it's as an attacker on the client side we can
send a send a request we can make the victim's browser send a request that request uh will not
trigger a a client-side path traversal because the use params on the client side in next will keep the
uh percent 2f encoded rather than um decoding it to a slash incur incurring a traversal when that actually
gets passed to the server side in some capacity there if a weight params is used it will it will actually
resolve those percent 2f's to uh slashes and incur some sort of server-side path traversal with the victim's
credentials that were sent from the browser correct and the reason behind this is that next has two
routing systems next is weird right because next is is supposed to be like the developer supposed to
kind of choose how much front-end and back-end they want there's a front-end only uh next which i didn't
really look at that much but in this situation that i'm describing which is basically a hybrid model
the the path is sent always starts at the server there's no front-end use params in this situation
the the url bar is sent to the server which parses it um in however way they want to do it
if they use await params that's what it's called the await function await params
that's url decoded by default and then if you're doing that and you pass that to a
slash api slash you know internal api.com slash uh slash this param you'll get secondary context
patch traversal okay so this doesn't rely on any client-side code at all
in this particular circumstance of of next uh there's no client-side code in this situation
it's going straight to the server the server's parsing it and passing it to the back end api
okay um there are front-end implementations but those mostly use um uh the the the non-vulnerable
code path yeah it's a little interesting though because like so so essentially what this is is a um
secondary context patch reversal yes is that is that what you're describing here that's correct
yeah i wonder if there's another layer though i wonder if there's a
client-side induced uh you know secondary context path reversal that that is happening here where it
doesn't you know i don't even know how this and maybe maybe i'm thinking about this wrong but like
if there is a client-side route that takes a path parameter puts that into an api request that is not
so we're not incurring the path reversal at this point right puts it into that api request with off
you know cookies which is not something we could have triggered from cross-site context puts it into
that you know sub resource request it is not incurring a path reversal at this point because it's not
decoded then that is sent to the server the server uses await params then it is decoded
and then that's not how that's not how that's not how next works yeah yeah the in this situation uh
you have to think of next a little different than react the um there there could be as you're
describing like a fetch request on the front end to an api but that is usually a different thing than
the back end of next yeah i see i see what you're saying because you see what i'm saying yeah it's
almost like a it's like a server-side single page yeah yeah next is weird i i guess some people want
server-side functions but but svelte is the same way where svelte has uh has a back end and a front
end and then maybe external apis and svelte is also vulnerable to the secondary context path traversal
and i did the the second answer to your question is i didn't look at the front and only implementation
of next js i only looked at this what i consider to be like the normal implementation of next js which
is that the path is sent to the server and the server does the stuff okay um but uh i'm not a next
developer so uh maybe uh there's other implementations that are have different um
i have different things um so that's that's one uh anyway sorry yeah no that that makes sense uh i
think that that's uh that's a valuable route and it's helpful i mean even if for no other thing than
just to feed this to ai as well and just be like hey point out to me the various spots in a code base
in a next code base where they're using await params versus you know whatever other way you're
supposed to process it i'm not gonna test for cspt on next using the path anymore i can i may
tech for secondary context but like there's no reason like next will not be vulnerable to that
interesting um in based on this research uh and neither will um solid solid which i had actually
hadn't heard that much of before this start solid start yeah because there's no vulnerable code pass
in those situations um for various reasons very interesting yeah that's that's uh but i will test for
it like crazy and view view is very vulnerable um yeah it seems like react is the most right you know
view is even more really okay you're right you're right you're right the wr encoding thing yeah is
uh is it makes it the most vulnerable yeah um but i hope they don't i mean i guess i hope they do
patch it i hope everything's secure right well we were kind of talking about this a little bit beforehand
like it's it's impossible to like sea surf you can patch right because there's some something you know
they did a really good job patching it with same site cookies right you know and ceaser still exists
but i mean for anybody who experienced the prevalence of sea surf prior to same site cookies
like our same site lacks default cookies it was way more um back then and and uh but this one you literally
can't fix because there's no way that they can fix it at the sync level right because uh you're doing
string oftentimes you're doing string concatenation prior to passing it to fetch or whatever right so
all it sees is a concatenated string right you know a one string that's all together and you can't fix
it at the source level or else you retroactively break a bunch of stuff um so i really think i think it's
it has to be on the developer level that's the problem and that's why it's always going to be
around because the developer is going to need the url decoded value at some point yeah that's that like
they need to url to code it if they don't do like it's going to break things if you don't do that so
then you have to always re-encode it when you're passing it to a a back-end to it that's the answer but
but it's not going to be fixed on the framework level i suppose i have a question i got a good
question if you all were on an app and you you can pick a framework if you want and you could only
register one username because i mean obviously we could just create a bunch of accounts or whatever
but you could register one username that would just break cspt if they're not blocking the right
characters what's that single username you would pick oh like what it'd be just like doctor percent 2f dot
booyakasha it's got to be booyakasha in the end dude so you would actually you would put it in
all three characters encoded i i to be honest i never i don't do it like that i don't that's not
how i test i don't like i don't create i would always test it low the nice thing about client-side
is you could you don't have to actually save the malicious username in order to see if it's vulnerable
you could always set a match and replace or just do something like that because it's client-side
yeah yeah i do think that certainly if you could smuggle uh those characters in the um you know
percent 2f the slash the backslash the um question mark the hashtag all of those sort of have meaning
from uh from that perspective um i also think just going back to what you were saying before though
about fixing it jd i think one of the things that could be interesting is providing developers with a
almost like prepared queries primitive inside of your your framework language so if you're doing a fetch
you provide like a base url and that base url has i mean you can't use a question mark or whatever
because question mark is you know query parameter start but like you you've got like a maybe like a
tilde or something like that that will get substituted with your prepared query you know values that
you provide in either in an array afterwards or in like a sequence of parameters to that function
and then it will handle the string interpolation itself because the value that you're providing is
always supposed to be you are you know just the value not not some path piece right does that would
that solve it you think no that that's the answer but i i will come back and say that is definitely the
answer that's right answer but like what did it take for sql injection to be this rare it took like an entire
the entire developer community getting together and and prioritizing this because it was such an impactful bug
and i would argue that the developers do not consider this as impactful as a bug and it would be
like think of how often they use dangerously set in their html when they shouldn't you know they i mean
i see that every app i see it every time every every react app they're using it like crazy they're
passing user controlled stuff in there passing api responses in there because they don't care as much
i mean maybe they do but it feels to me like sql injection is something they took much more seriously
certainly and i and i think also another piece of that was that the whole ecosystem turned over
since sql existed right sql was one of sql injection was one of the first you know vulnerabilities that
really got prevalence and then since then every single framework has been rewritten and you know has
you know shifted to a different framework or evolved in a serious way so it makes it easy for them to like
have those primitives change right but i do think like if a good step in the right direction against
cspt would would maybe be the chrome team pushing a fetch um a fetch version or a fetch uh alternative
that has the string interpolation safe fetch yeah safe yeah that's a really good idea but see you can't
rename i was gonna say like or renaming fetch bad fetch you know bad fetch yeah you can't can't do it
fetch is very vulnerable yeah fetch is the most vulnerable thing and i mean that's not true
everything in javascript is vulnerable but fetch is not a safe function it as you have said it takes out
tabs yeah um that which is the best waft bypass i've ever it's honestly i mean i don't know i'll say it
percent two f percent zero nine percent five c is i'm sorry dot dot dot sorry percent two f percent two e
percent zero nine percent two e percent five c is the best wap bypass i've ever used in my entire life
i love it i use it all the time and it works 100 of the time i haven't seen a wap oh i don't know i don't
know if we're gonna let that i don't know if we're gonna let that run uh richard we might bleep that i
don't know that's it's so good but it's so good i mean i'm sorry to say you can't bleep it on this
podcast you're true you're true that's the point of this podcast yeah so anyway that is a very powerful
laugh bypass ryan i know you're listening to this don't you ryan turn the ryan turn it off man turn it
off i was just thinking about ryan i was thinking about him freaking when i said that providers
listening to this podcast um but yeah totally i i agree i think that that is very strong um and and
fetch certainly is vulnerable um i will say there is one more vulnerable though which is the freaking um
which one is it i think it's axios some version actually was really yeah that will like auto run
the js code in a jsonp callback if you know that yeah yeah there's like there's one of them i i gotta
go look it up maybe i'll put it in the show notes but there is i believe some versions of axios or maybe
it's one of the jquery um ones if you know if you pass traversal if you client-side pass traversal it
to a jsonp endpoint it will just run the javascript callback oh my god you know i think axios is a
wrapper around fetch yeah like i think my axios uses fetch right like it's like i haven't looked at the axios
code but i guarantee you axios demo has looked at that code and i'm going to ask him right after this
yeah he knows exactly why it's doing that i think it's probably xhr um request uh because axios is a
little older and i think fetch is like a uh a newer i say newer now i'm getting i'm aging myself a little
bit here but like uh you know newer primitive um okay awesome yeah so that we did go down a little bit of a
bit of a rabbit rabbit trail there but fixing cspt you know it would be cool if the browsers put in
some string interpolation included um fetch function call uh to try to get those resolved and then have
the frameworks try to adopt that at a framework level yeah that that's a good fix uh so let's continue
to go through some of the research here uh on the path stuff i mean we can just look at this maybe it's
easier for everybody in the audio medium to just you know talk through this table essentially but we've
got react router that decodes react routers use params decodes percent to f to slash and percent to e
uh percent to e to dot dot everything and w rld codes as well yeah and w rl um the only other place we
see w rl encoding there's no other place we see w rl encoding without developer sourced code in any of
the other top frameworks is that accurate in the path that's correct in the path yes um in the path
where it gets really hit or miss is do they double decode percent to e across various frameworks um most of
the time we see yes but there are some no's that's at solid start and nuxt server level they'll just leave
it straight as is right okay that's right and then um another thing is i need to include
backslash in this i i didn't do it partly because this is the longest article i've ever written
including in medicine this is very long um it's very long and i and i could i also like kind of
didn't do as much on the hash because it's so i think it's like 15 pages it's like some amazing amount
of yeah uh so i break down the code paths for each individual framework it's very helpful that's
kind of what i i wanted to do it and also um i'm also going to include the labs that i made so you
could test this yourself uh you can run the lab and then i'll show you one of the labs yeah while
you're pulling that up i would like to ask you can you can you explain the difference between um
wild card params and i think there's two ways of describing wild cards right so we've got you know
in our classic example about about slash xss doctor right that xss doctor is a dynamic piece
i think they're called dynamic parameters and wild card parameters or something like that can you
explain the difference of those and how those are different frameworks the answer is actually uh
something we didn't talk about is that basically what is what is happening in each of these functions
is that it's building a regex whenever you have a dynamic parameter or or a query parameter uh it's
basically building a unique regex uh in a particular way so uh like the use params is going to have one
regex and then the splat parameter is going to have the splat the uh the wild card is going to have
another different regex and the use params for example breaks on slash whereas um like the splat
parameter it's just anything anything you've put in between whatever you know in that area is gonna be
taken exactly there's not gonna split on anything it's a dot star that's that's what it does in react for
example it's basically slash dot star slash okay and it won't differentiate so that's that's something
i want to make a little bit clearer for the listener so um let me see if i can find it in the report while
i'm talking about it but what what is the difference between like where do we see what what does a splat
parameter look like or a splat path look like in the definition and what does its alternative i guess
a dynamic parameter look like oh so like a dynamic parameter it reacts a great example for all
these things so it's like it would be slash colon user id would be uh a regular dynamic parameter
and then it would literally say like slash files slash star is a great example um for a splat parameter
because it um it's like anything you put in there and i think one of the reasons to do that is
uh they may have file names they may have you know it may be different you may want to capture the dot
stuff like that whereas um that that's the reason you do it it's oftentimes that was the example i gave
a slash file slash star it's the most vulnerable code pattern okay in react okay so two ways of of
defining dynamic path you have we're going to stick with our same example about slash star and that will
match about slash xss doctor slash abc123 yeah and and we've also got um about slash colon username
yeah whatever right and that's right and when we do that if we put in something like about slash rhino
reader then username gets populated as rhino reader but if we put about slash rhino reader slash abc123
that abc123 is not put into username just or it doesn't match the route or or or does it just populate
it depends what you're doing it depends how you're doing it but if it if it's like slash file slash star
you could put anything in the world after that files thing whereas if it's just the user id uh it
depends i think uh the for for use params for example you can't put a real slash it will it will be it
will uh if that's where it land um that's it you could put a percent two f even if you okay so let me ask
you this one splat plus no no splat isn't going to end up and use params so correct it's a different
so if if they're using a splat route which is just about slash star and then it's like anything after
about just gets put in there but it doesn't get populated as a parameter it just okay okay so one of
these is a wild card path and one of these is a dynamic variable in the path is that yeah accurate
that's exactly that's exactly that's how it's it was meant to be used yeah and they and that's that's
how it's meant to be used and it again it's all as vulnerable as the developer wants it to be they
could easily just take a splat parameter and do save things with it okay but it's harder to do that
that's a really good that's a really good signal piece for us though is is when there is a splat
parameter b or a splat path defined right which is these star wildcard paths and we see them trying
to parse a path parameter out of that wildcard defined route splat splat route so to speak um
then that is something that should go ding ding ding ding in our head like hey maybe we should look
into that a little bit more because that's not how that's supposed to be done yeah okay
i think what i'm gonna do is i'll just to show you this differentiation i'll um i'm gonna show you
the lab this is kind of how i learned it and this helps this can help you so like let's say here right
this in this situation we're using use params and so what's happening here is that this is what's the
developer is actually doing there's making a constant called user id and that equals use params and that
is running through this function right so it's taking this which is the user id which i've url encoded
and then it shows what gets back so user id equals the decoded version okay and then you could see that
i even fetched yeah see and then it's requesting this so i could even do my favorite is that dot dot percent
two f by this he means it makes the request that is constructed based on the decoded username yeah
and then you know as this is how i would do this um now i even uh where i put in three percent two f's and
then that's we're back at the api secret endpoint okay yeah so what this this is a hands-on lab that is
demonstrating for those of you all uh you know that you can traverse all using use params the use the
encoded path that you say parameter that's set in by the path gets pulled into a variable by use params
that is decoded and when you can concatenate that with fetch it traverses all the way back and one of
your parts of your flow uh jd is to um go all the way back down to the document root so you can hit yeah
and then if you're if there's something appended at the end um you know you could put throw that in
there too the hash and then also if you see the w r l encoded i threw it the percent 25 to f now what's
interesting that i found that i couldn't figure out was a lower case all right i don't know well you've
got 25 to f to f um well anyway the lower case 2f here won't work really yeah if you do it like that you
see very odd oh it's very odd right hey that is a super good takeaway whoa i totally just got screwed
on a bunch of bugs then probably so what you're saying is that percent 25 to f lowercase functions
differently than percent 25 to get f uppercase and i cannot figure out show me show me you have to do it
we have to do it we have to do it we have to do it in a different window you have to do it in a different
window uh because if you do it in the same window so wait well it cashed
yeah yeah that's why add a cash buster all right uh i just do it like this because i and i always
preserve disabled cash all right so you got this so big percent 2f see yep okay so it's being converted
on percent 25 to f so that works right wow yep whoa here the lower case doesn't work okay whoa what
that that seems like something are you sure that's not your lab bro i don't know man i don't understand
it i couldn't figure it out from the code either so it could be my lab we had to kind of i i couldn't
figure it out but i mean your lab has got to be a reflection of at least some production systems it's
just doing this yeah like i don't understand that would do it is literally just taking a vanilla modern
react and doing this and then and then reflecting it when we when we um when we ship this research
that needs to be like bolded and at the top that is like i have been screwed by that tell us tell us
why justin tell us why just okay because like i off i'm only do percent lowercase percent uh to lower
case f i've never capitalized an f for i mean what he's saying is because you're like typing it fast
right like it's like you're just like yeah it's the same thing me too and then what is what he's saying
here is that if you have a lowercase f it is not being decoded in an uppercase f it is being decoded
what the but you should see that stuff right like we should be seeing that when we're testing that
it's not working but i guess we would just say it's not working and wro encoding is not working
yeah what the heck dude it's weird right okay i'm tripping a little bit we're gonna have to
even see it like i my my app is extremely simple you know it's just taking the thing and so i i don't
i can't imagine that it's my app because wow listeners i'm sorry i know that we're kind of freaking
out uh and for those of you that are listening by audio you probably don't have a lot of a big idea
of what's going on here but essentially what he just showed is that in react use params which is
one of the most common ways i would say probably the most common way to get path parameters in single
page applications period uh if you use percent 25 2f lowercase it does not decode to slash and if you use
percent 25 2f uppercase f it does what the frick let's see let's see what it's like with with with
backslash yeah and a bunch of and you know what's weird is is okay dude there's some sort of caching
no it's got to be some caching bro well what is that no no no no wait no it can't be it didn't
look like caching to me when i was watching jd redo it it looked completely dude no it's legit man
it's freaking legit it's legit yeah holy crap but i don't understand why that's the case let's get
demo i mean let's get hold on all right we just summoned the the client side you know conclave of
minds or whatever here to try to figure out what happened here and yeah this is legit so uh exercise
doctor dude give me something man like this is a very legit finding one of the best ones we've had live
on the pod i think uh but the tldr of it if as i understand and you can correct me if i'm wrong
is that the reason why react double url encoding only decodes back to a slash for the capital f
in percent 25 to capital f is because of this line right here line 118 in match path um i don't know the
name of the file in the source code but it does a replace for percent to capital f and swaps it to
slash and it does not do that in a case insensitive way so uppercase f will be mapped to this slash and
lowercase f will not be and that is where the differential is occurring is that correct yeah
and that actually was put in after another double url encoding bug was reported to react
as an issue not as a as a bug bounty bug and they and this is how they fixed it and they reintroduced
this problem and i guess made it wow dude i have missed so many cspts because of this i never use a
capital f i will always be using capital f now yeah that's crazy maybe both or maybe you have
to try both in all these situations another thing to try both on man it's like oh here we go but yeah
dude that is a zero day gadget in react router that is uh super nuts so great find and uh yeah i'm glad
we get the truth is that to the community there's a lot here like there's way more than i've found too if
if you if you just like look at any of these frameworks and you look deeply into the way that the routing
happens you're gonna find weird stuff that goes on i think just conceptually as well like looking for
replaces that are not case you know insensitive is really good idea you know uh i think that there's
a lot of scenarios where that will slide past and allow you to bypass something yeah um very cool man
well we just got super derailed and burnt a bunch of time um rezo do you have to go or are you good
to stay for a little bit longer yeah i'll drop here in like a minute or two so you'll just see me drop
off but okay all right well thanks for joining us man um so we're getting the rest of the path stuff
uh you know essentially you've outlined all of the different frameworks here so far we've talked about
wild card or or um splat paths and actual dynamic paths that's good um double url encoding happens
in react router but everything else does not um and our fetch will automatically pull out you know
percent zero nine or tabs uh which helps with wi-fi passes um let's let's move unless you've got
anything else on path parameters maybe we we talk a little bit more into the server-side rendering thing
or yeah that's interesting just quickly on query parameters yeah they're almost always decoded and
that's kind of how it should be yes like that you know that is what it is they it's it's a feature
not a bug uh but if the query parameters pass to a fetch it's gonna almost always lead to um cspt
um or uh but the i think the more before we even went into this capital lowercase app the most interesting
thing i found on this in this research was like i was looking for cspt but there are a bunch of these
frameworks that are that are hybrid or or server-side and those it is a risk of secondary path traversal
yeah secondary context path traversal for sure yeah and that's because the the client-side route is
not encoding in the in the back end it is right just like we talked about with the um with the next
such a situation was there anything else that you wanted to cover there i know that there was some
some pieces of like um there's actual ssrf versus client-side or secondary context path traversal
where do we land on and one of the frameworks that bypasses like a hook as well or something or
i think the interesting the thing to really focus on is when you're doing the secondary context
path traversal it's blind in the beginning right because it's happening on the server as all secondary
context possible is but in something like react you're going to get 500s when you have stuff like
that so you should be testing in things like svelte which are not that much written in svelte but uh and
next you should be doing putting these path traversal payloads um to test for secondary context
path traversal but you should be doing the thing that was spoken about uh on the pod with secondary
kind of path traversal where you do the percent 2f let's say slash settings slash xss doctor percent 2f
dot dot percent 2f xss doctor yes and uh and that if that doesn't give a 500 that is suggestive yes
that you're that means that there's some context path normal is that you take a valid value valid value
slash dot dot slash slash uh you know yeah value valid value all right let me say it one more time
valid value slash dot dot slash valid value right yeah okay and basically you do invalid value and you
get 500 let's say and then you do valid value and you don't like next give a lot of 500s right uh if
if you're messing up on the back end uh and that that's a nice takeaway of that sort of research excellent
excellent man um see you guys all right yeah you're dropping peace rezo um all right well that that
brings us through um sort of out of the path related stuff so query parameters almost all decoded
but you and i were saying you know we do find more path reversals in path parameters rather than
query parameters i did want to bring up a little bit of a interesting one though you can get a sort of
variant of client-side path traversals a little bit more frequently in um career parameters where
you're either injecting into a part of the domain or you are in injecting into a relative path where
you control the full relative path and it is just i know the target i know what you're talking about
but that that's very impactful when that happens when you're injecting into a domain uh it's it's like a
built-in uh open redirect as well yeah right so i guess do you have any nomenclature you use for
those sort of scenarios or how do we yes like fetch hijacking or right no like what if what if the
beginning of the what if it's you're injecting into into the username and password part of the url so i you
know because sometimes they don't they they don't realize you're doing that and i'll use the same my
favorite website in hacking is the port swigger academy url parsing what's it called a lab or something
uh pull that up because it's the best it is the greatest thing ever to study this thing i use this
every day i'm obsessed with this for a lot of a lot of reasons right here that thing yes first just
study it like without using it like this just study it because this will tell you everything you
need to know about about how urls are parsed um and about what you could try to try different things
and i i'll use this in that situation because you don't like you're injecting into it and you don't
really know how it's being handled or you have to figure it out and you could do all these different
cool things totally dude yeah this is a super helpful cheat sheet and i really appreciate that
port swigger releases this uh yeah and then another trick maybe i shouldn't i is that i will every
single time i'm looking at oauth if you could inject into that a username or password before the at
only if that is the case i will run this entire list over that um that and and i've found like a lot
of bugs do oh yeah yeah very common very common and now we know thanks to your to your research today
that we also need to upper and lower everything as well which is great uh crazy for us so yeah this is
definitely a good cheat sheet we'll put it in the um we'll put it in the description of the episode um
okay awesome so that that is it largely for query i i call that other that other variant um fetch
hijacking i don't know if that's the correct term or maybe like client-side request hijacking uh but
then it c s h h or r h yeah it's a little off but um you know hijacking a client-side request that is
being sent uh pretty rare very impactful typically when you can do it um if you're injecting into the
hosting anywhere i once got uh the only time i've ever had a web worker injection is that is that they
were injecting into the host name from a query parameter i love that i love that too man and then
also um it's so definitely the the query parameter uh you know actually just controlling the host name
itself but also if it's a relative path and you've got it that's one of the things that won't pop up in
network so you've got to actually change you know the network tab you got to trace the sync or the
source um no trace the sync right where it's actually sending the request put a you know breakpoint
right at the fetch request and see what is being passed into the fetch request because if they're
passing in a slash rather than the full https colon whatever and you can make it to slash slash or slash backslash or
slash tab slash right all of that's going to get resolved to slashes uh which is going to allow it
to become an arbitrary um you know an absolute path rather than a uh relative path and speaking of that
it's actually pretty hard sometimes to find those and it's also very hard i find to find the sync of the
fetch where it's parsing the jason that is i spend but if you guys if whoever wants to get into client
side like do that a couple times and that will help you with dynamic analysis a lot because sometimes
it's in a completely separate place uh i don't know it's not it's not always like fetch then uh jason jason
parsed like it like it's not they pass the promises around it's like they're all over the place yeah
yeah one time i was looking at something like that for like a day and demoed found it in like four
seconds freaking hate that man and i'm like how did you find that he's like looking at the app
he's just one of those guys that uh just has that like just you could just slurp it all up him and
uriota are the two and dude i'm so salty that demo lives right up the street for me too i'm so mad that
he is in my city like that makes me so mad um yeah thank god nobody in miami can hack yeah oh yeah
there are some great if you're a great miami hacker i apologize and call me i'd love to hack with you
he'll really try to impress you if you submit a report first if you submit a report first i'll go crazy
you know what would be like the best troll ever would be to like say hey access doc you want to
like do full collab on this like you know target and then but secretly you've been working on it for
three weeks beforehand and you have like 10 bugs and then and then as soon as they're like oh i found
one i found one it'll cost you a couple grand but it'll drive jd nuts you know like how do you find
that looking at the app yeah looking at the app just look i just looked at it did you you didn't look at
it because i looked at it yeah jd could you like spend more time hacking i feel like oh my gosh
um all right last piece of of stuff from this uh research that i'd like to go over is uh the
custom sinks that uh you know incur fetch requests to be made in the various frameworks so i'm gonna go
ahead and share my screen again can you talk a little bit about those that you discovered in various
frameworks so i mean there are actually others uh this was like uh like that are a little bit more
like like i keep talking about demo turbo he did has wonderful research in react xss sinks that i did
not include here because that's his research but like the most basic ones are dangerous to set inner
html for react and next shares that in view and nuxt there's something called a v dash html which is
similar angular uses um this bypass secure security trust html um svelte kit has just curly braces so
there's a bunch of different ways to get html triggered in all the various frameworks and i think that that is
certainly it's nice to have this list at the end right that you they included at the end but what
i'm talking about more is this guy um this guy right here the url for find record so this is a
built-in version of fetch essentially right like fetch is powering you're talking about the sinks yeah
yeah yeah yeah is that yeah that's it yeah that's that's basically the whole thing but yeah it's very
interesting there's a couple of those but that's that's the most uh that's the most the most prominent
one where they like wrap something around fetch that makes it more vulnerable okay so explain this
one for me so an ember you obviously you can use fetch right but then there's also a built-in utility
that you see them using a lot of times that also is not doing um traversal even though you're passing
in say what seems weird to me here right is you're passing into this id and model name or whatever right
and it's actually like so you're not it's not like you're passing in a url you are passing in
it's almost like the interpolation thing that we we said we wanted right but then they're just not
sanitizing it right exactly right yeah they're introducing they're basically introducing a bug this way
in this custom right it's very it's very interesting behavior okay and this is an ember and and is it
always url for find record or is there a different structure no that's it that's what the function's
called okay all right and yeah i think this is a really good thing to keep looking for in other
frameworks is like when i'm you know scrolling through the code when i see url for find record
um you know i'm not necessarily thinking oh this is going to be vulnerable right but uh this guy right
here will be creating these you know urls that uh will be then passed to fetch and it's doing the
string interpolation but it's not actually encoding any of the values itself and that's another thing to
think about too is that there's another sync that i didn't even talk about here which is the server
the server may normalize url encoded and that's very common uh the api itself that's a great point
yeah so um i always that's usually the first thing i test because then you don't have to think about
this then it gets passed to fetch fetch could do whatever it wants and the back end is gonna url
to code for you yeah um then you could triple url encodes react oh my gosh we're getting to crazy
layers here triple url encode yeah and then also sometimes you know if you can smuggle in a percent
3f or something like that in those sort of environments that's a really strong signal you
know if it's taking your percent 2f it's still processing it as a path separator very strong
signal for um for cash poisoning um very much so and it would be hard for waft to get all these oh yeah for
sure yeah i mean there's too much variation yeah all right well if you guys haven't uh seen the value
already of reading this write-up by xss doctor that will be on lab.ctpb.show then uh you're crazy
uh so definitely go read it read it thoroughly uh and i'm not gonna lie to you guys i sat down and it
took me a long time to get through it even as somebody who's you know professional with client-side
stuff but the value that i got out of just reading this is very very high and i think you guys will as
well and do the labs the labs is is even more important because if you do the labs with it you'll
understand you like play with it and you'll find stuff i didn't find you know with with those labs you
do weird stuff to the parameters and see what you get yes totally um dude thank you so much for for
coming on and for dazzling us with all this uh it was awesome and yeah it's the price is right i am on
the price is right right now and i am a contestant i'm that excited and like those people on that show
awesome man well well gg let's get back to the hacking itself then yeah peace that's the pod
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all
if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there